bienvenidos a este especial de noticias
en france 24 es 4 de julio día de la
independencia de eeuu una fecha clave
para el gobierno de obeid en que en su
primer discurso televisado declaró esta
jornada como su meta para haber vacunado
al 70% de los estadounidenses nos
conectamos en este momento con la casa
blanca con las palabras del mandatario
grandes ventajas contra este virus que
ha tomado vidas ha permitido que los
niños vuelvan a la escuela ha permitido
que la escuela que la economía vuelva
no se equivoquen en esto el kobe 19 no
ha sido vencido aún todos sabemos que
hay variantes muy poderosas que viene
dirigido como la variante delta
pero la mejor defensa ante estas
variantes es ser vacunado
compañeros estadounidenses esto lo más
patriótico que pueden hacer así que por
favor si no se han vacunado vayan vayan
ahora por ustedes mismos por sus seres
queridos por su comunidad y por su país
saben algo
así es como vamos a vender a las
variantes vamos a tener que proteger el
progreso que hemos logrado nunca jamás
queremos estar donde estuvimos hace un
año hoy así que hoy aunque el virus no
ha sido vencido sabemos algo ya no
controlan nuestras vidas ya no paralizan
nuestra nación ya está en nuestras manos
asegurarnos de que nunca suceda de nuevo
y por esa razón podemos agradecer a los
científicos a los investigadores a los
educadores a todos los trabajadores
esenciales de primera línea como ustedes
hoy
y ustedes nos dieron la oportunidad de
ver la luz en la oscuridad espero que
sepan que ustedes el pueblo
estadounidense
han hecho parte de uno de los logros más
impresionantes del estadounidense pero
en ese momento de alegría sabemos
que este día nos toca duro a los que
hemos perdido seres queridos yo les he
dicho antes cada día yo llevo en este
bolsillo una carta con todo mi horario
detrás de este horario en esa tarjeta no
tengo la cifra de estadounidenses que
han perdido la vida por el el
número preciso hoy ese nombre ese número
de 600 tres mil 816 personas que ha
perdido sus vidas
esposos esposas
madres y padres hijos e hijas hermanos y
hermanas abuelos amigos vecinos colegas
también hay que recordar a todos
aquellos que perdieron durante este año
que nuestras familias han perdido
personas a otras causas distintas
alcobas en giros crueles del del destino
hay personas que han perdido seres
queridos personas que no han podido
llorar los que no han podido encontrar
un cierre cada uno de ellos significaba
todo el mundo alguna persona que dejaron
atrás y aquellos que han atravesado todo
esto saben que la sanación
en la sanación hay que recordar hay que
recordarlos a ellos y lo haremos
tendremos el compromiso de recordarlo
siempre eso es lo que haremos
hablando dijo que eeuu es único a
diferencia de cualquier otra nación en
la tierra si fuimos fundados basados en
una idea estos valores para nosotros son
evidentes de que todos son creados
iguales gymnos por su creador y cada uno
tiene derechos y venerables entre ellos
la libertad la vida el derecho a
perseguir la libertad y aunque no hemos
vivido completamente con esos valores no
nos hemos rendido nos siguen animando
nos recuerdan
uy qué
es lo que mejor podemos hacer en nuestro
mejor momento nosotros creemos en la
honestidad y en la decencia en tratar a
todo el mundo con dignidad y con respeto
darle a todos una gran oportuno por
tunidad justa sin demonizar a nadie
sin darle espacio ni refugio al odio sin
dejar a nadie detrás
lideramos por el poder de nuestro
ejemplo no por el ejemplo de nuestro
poder somos parte de algo que es mucho
más grande que nosotros somos un faro
para el mundo es el código es el código
único de eeuu es lo que somos a todos
los miembros del servicio que están aquí
hoy a todas las familias a todos los que
están en servicio en cualquier parte del
mundo es el mayor honor de mi vida
servir como comandante en jefe de
ustedes
jill y yo
[Aplausos]
jing y nuestra familia entera les
agradece por el servicio y el sacrificio
como tantas familias militares
que piensan en sus seres queridos que
están en servicio pensamos en nuestro
hijo hoy todos ustedes hacen parte de
una gran cadena de patriotas que juraron
defender esta nación con su vida y con
su honor defender la democracia
alrededor del mundo en nombre de la
libertad del juego limpio en nombre de
la paz y la seguridad y la oportunidad
por la causa de la justicia por el alma
de eeuu en sí misma la defensa de todo
lo que amamos no descansa solamente en
sus hombros descansa en los de todos
cada uno de nosotros cada estadounidense
cada día se nos recuerda que no hay nada
garantizado en nuestra democracia nada
garantizado en nuestro estilo de vida
tenemos que luchar por ello defenderlo
ganarlo
damas y caballeros eso depende de todos
nosotros la búsqueda de la vida es el
derecho a votar pública el derecho de
que se voto cuenta y no hay el derecho
el derecho de respirar aire fresco de
beber agua limpia y saber que nuestros
hijos y nietos
estarán a salvo de pemex por
generaciones venideras
el derecho va a llegar tan lejos como el
talento no podrá llevar sin límites de
barrera de privilegio o poder
es uno de los grandes dones es el
espíritu de independencia pensemos en
eso en nuestra capacidad de vernos a
nosotros mismos
de vernos completos de vernos
honestamente
lo que hemos hecho bien lo que hemos
hecho mal es una medida de la grandeza
de eeuu somos una gran nación
no buscamos ocultar los malos textos
queremos corregirlos la historia nos
dice que cuando estamos unidos cuando
nos unimos bajo una causa como cuando
nos vemos no solamente como republicanos
e demócratas sino como estadounidenses
simplemente no hay límites a lo que
podemos lograr
y ninguno
y hoy vemos los resultados de la unidad
en el propósito al forjar lo que estamos
haciendo de su nación porque juntos
estamos venciendo al virus juntos
estamos respirando estamos dando de vida
nuestra comida y juntos
rescataremos a nuestro pueblo de la
división del desespero pero juntos como
nación durante el último año hemos vídeo
a través de nuestros días más oscuros
ahora creo honestamente les doy mi
palabra como bailén si creo que vamos a
ver nuestro futuro más brillante
foxx damas y caballeros
[Aplausos]
esta es una nación especial una gran
nación y hay una verdad atemporal en
eeuu la idea más poderosa en la historia
del mundo
está en el corazón de la gente este país
que está para limitações personas sin
importar la raza la adversidad sin
importar su género con su orientación
sexual sin importar las discapacidades
sin importar la fe esto palpita en el
corazón de ricos y pobres y une a todos
los estados unidos cuando nuestros
ancestros eran nativos en esta tierra
sea que fueran nativos o ser atraídos
por esclavitud ya que ustedes sean
inmigrantes de generaciones anteriores
como mi familia o lleguen hoy buscando
construir una mejor vida para su familia
como nuestros compañeros estadounidenses
algo es que acabo de juramentar en la
casa blanca hace 2 días
y el credo estadounidense usamos esta
frase el credo estadounidense
es que todos somos iguales creados
iguales eso fue escrito hace mucho
tiempo pero la genialidad de que cada
generación estados estadounidenses se
haya expandido más y más para incluir a
aquellos que fueron excluidos antes por
eso es que esto jamás reunida polvo en
nuestro libro de historia por eso es que
sigue vivo en nuestro corazón en el
trabajo de nuestras manos vivo no
solamente la historia que leemos sino en
la historia que estamos haciendo
compañeros estadounidenses ahora somos
los guardianes de esa idea
estadounidense depende de nosotros
salvar la preservarla construir a partir
de ella y yo sé que lo haremos en este
día sagrado yo miro a esos monumentos
que están en nuestro modelo nacional y
más allá en los corazones de la gente en
todo el territorio y yo sé esto nunca
ha sido nunca ha estado bien apostar en
contra de eeuu jamás jamás
tenemos que recordar quiénes somos somos
los eeuu de américa
y no hay nada nada que no podamos hacer
si lo hacemos juntos
damas y caballeros
bendiga a todos y que dios proteja a
nuestras tropas muchas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la obra del presidente joe biden desde
el jardín sur de la casa blanca y vamos
a ampliar esta información conectamos a
esta hora con nuestro corresponsal en la
capital estadounidense
cristóbal vázquez cristóbal buenas
tardes estamos ante un discurso sentido
un discurso lleno de patriotismo en el
día de la independencia en el que el
presidente mencionó a 603.000 víctimas
del coi 19 habló de los derechos a la
vida a la justicia incluso el derecho al
voto habla claramente de unirse bajo una
causa común qué es lo que está haciendo
en este momento del país eso es lo que
él resalta sin embargo tenemos que decir
que esta era una fecha en la que bardem
había establecido una meta que no se
logró de acuerdo con los centros para la
prevención y el control de enfermedades
el 66 7 por ciento de los adultos han
recibido al menos una dosis de vacunas y
él aspiraba que fuese un 70 por ciento
tenemos que hablar en principio que
bailen en estos momentos es el anfitrión
de una barbacoa con alrededor de 1000
personas en la casa blanca
pues es un mensaje bastante particular
en este momento porque está luchando
contra haber disminuido los índices de
muertes de contagios pero con otras
condiciones que están afectando al país
en estos momentos entonces en principio
cristóbal le preguntó qué mensaje busca
enviar by den con esta reunión que
organiza la casa blanca- quiénes son
estos invitados a los que se refirió
como personas que han luchado contra el
virus se sabe si están vacunados
sí sí están vacunados de hecho antes de
entrar a la casa blanca antes de ir a
celebrar en este patio sur en el césped
sur de la casa blanca pues las
autoridades de la casa blanca los
organismos de salud se aseguraron que
estas personas estuvieran vacunadas son
más de 1000 personas que estuvieron que
están en este momento aquí en la casa un
al que yo estoy a una cuadra y media y
las calles alrededor del centro de
washington están completamente llenas de
estadounidenses que han salido además
acercándose a la national molt en un
nacional que es el lugar donde mejor se
ven los fuegos artificiales fuegos
artificiales que durarán cerca de 17
minutos pero valentina para responder
concretamente a su pregunta los tres
mensajes principales fueron los
siguientes primero gratitud a estas a
estas personas a estos primeros personas
que estaban en la primera línea de
respuesta frente a la pandemia en estos
casi 16 meses de pandemia que ha vivido
en eeuu pues el presidente bailén quiso
agradecerles haber puesto en riesgo sus
vidas para
a tratar de ayudar a las familias y a
las personas más afectadas en esta
pandemia fue entonces este mensaje de
gratitud a los primeros respondiste si a
las fuerzas militares que estuvieron ahí
presentes estos son sobre todo los
invitados gente que estuvo en la primera
línea y militares los que están en este
momento en la casa blanca celebrando
esta gran barbacoa esta gran fiesta que
pues nos tenía acostumbrados georges a
bollywood reagan también hizo fiestas
pero que don otro no durante sus cuatro
años de gobierno nos celebró no hizo
estas fiestas en el en la zona sur de la
casa blanca el segundo mensaje pues es
lamentar las a más de 600.000 muertes
que han sufrido ha sufrido estados
unidos precisamente por el coi y él le
mencionó obviamente el tema de la nueva
variante la variable
la variable la variante delta perdón y
pues el tercer mensaje es pedirle
implorarle a los estadounidenses que por
favor se pongan la vacuna usted ha
mencionado bien cerca del 67 por ciento
los estadounidenses tienen
una vacuna pero pues no llega o apenas
supera el 50 por ciento los
estadounidenses que tienen ya las dos
vacunas están completamente vacunados
así que es un gran reto que tiene yo
bailén para lograr ese 70 por ciento o
más que según pues el docentes de salud
en eeuu es la cifra clave para asegurar
esa inmunidad de rebaño se hará la
fiesta en los contados minutos empiezan
ya entonces los fuegos artificiales en
la casa blanca- fuegos artificiales que
comparado al año anterior le mencionaba
durarán a cerca de 17 minutos el año
anterior durante la administración de
donald trump pues fueron 35 minutos de
fuegos artificiales pero pues el
ambiente obviamente es bastante más
tranquilo bastante más normal a lo que
se vivió el año anterior en plena
pandemia y precisamente ese era uno de
los mensajes principales también en este
discurso tratar de transmitirles desde
la casa blanca desde los organismos de
control y de salud a los estadounidenses
que
la cosa va bien y que pronto se va a
poder lograr llegar a la normalidad de
hoy un último dato en 20 estados aquí en
eeuu ya se logró precisamente esa cifra
de el 70 por ciento de adultos vacunados
pero pues obviamente quedan 30 31
estados que no logran esa cifra y ahí
entonces queda ese resto para eeuu
cristóbal justamente a esto hacía
referencia al presidente cuando dice que
el hobbit no ha sido vencido es el dice
que la mejor defensa contra este virus
es ser vacunado y que vacunarse es lo
más patriótico que pueden hacer los
estadounidenses para vencer las
variantes usted ya lo mencionaba
anteriormente pero le pregunto cuál es
la actual situación del país con
factores como la variante delta la
vacunación que se torna lenta desde hace
algún tiempo y el uso de mascarillas que
ya no es obligatorio para personas
completamente vacunadas en prácticamente
toda la nación
exacto no es obligatorio sin embargo
precisamente la variante delta que está
cobrando
bastante riesgo acá en este país de
hecho un cuarto de los nuevos casos
corresponde a la variable delta y sobre
todo en estados del sur en misisipí
alabama en georgia allá hay bastante
contagio porque precisamente son los
estados que menos atención le han parado
le han puesto a las medidas de
precaución y precisamente en algunos
condados de esos estados y en algunos
estados incluso ya se están replanteando
nuevamente las medidas de empezar a
portar máscaras a nivel federal se había
dicho que el porte de máscara ya no era
obligatorio pero precisamente teniendo
en cuenta lo contagiosa que es esta
variable del delta y teniendo en cuenta
que cerca del 25 por ciento de los
nuevos casos en eeuu son de variable
delta pues varios estados varios
gobernadores ya han empezado a decir que
hay que empezar a considerar nuevamente
el porte de máscaras en espacios
cerrados y con bastante aglomeración y
algo que no se ve no se ve en el centro
de washington en este momento cuando
llegando a este lugar camine las calles
del centro cerca nacional
cerca a la casa blanca y la gente iba
tranquilamente sin mascarilla un poco
con esa confianza pero sin duda es algo
que le preocupa al presidente de byd en
quien el viernes cuando él iba camino a
la web bolton a delaware donde estaba
hace unas horas antes de venir acá
washington a esta celebración del 4 de
julio se le preguntó precisamente este
viernes si estaba preocupado por un
brote un posible brote de la variable
delta y él respondió que sí que le
preocupaba que el tema de la propagación
rápida que ha tenido esta variable en
eeuu pero que no le preocupaba que no
pero te mayor un brote mayúsculo fuese a
pasar en eeuu del lado de esta variable
delta precisamente porque según él y
según anthony fauci pues cuando un
estadounidense a una persona tiene la
vacuna de facer de moderna de johnson
johnson pues el riesgo de contagio es
mínimo dicen que de hecho estas vacunas
pueden pues hacer frente en un 88 por
ciento
este virus en un 88% esta variable de
este virus en un 88% si se tiene
precisamente este tipo de vacunas así
que desde la casa a una casilla y
preocupación por la variable delta pero
dicen que esto no va a generar un nuevo
brote grande recordemos que pues el
promedio de casos en la última semana en
eeuu ha sido de 10.000 casos diarios y
pues es una cifra bastante positiva
comparado obviamente con lo que teníamos
a principio de año
cristóbal estado mencionada el
presidente ha hecho un llamado casi una
súplica para que las personas se vacunen
en un sondeo publicado por the
washington post y abc news de hoy indica
que más de un 70% de las personas que no
han recibido ninguna dosis no estaría
dispuesta a vacunarse a qué se debe este
fenómeno
hay sin duda desinformación y sin duda
la polarización en el país continúa es
decir
muchos republicanos muchos seguidores de
donald trump pues ven el tema de la
vacunación con un tinte político con un
filtro político y dicen que vacunarse
pues es de alguna manera caer de alguna
manera sobre el mandato y sobre las
intenciones políticas que tienen los
demócratas con eeuu así que en muchos
estados del sur en muchas muchas áreas
republicanas no vacunarse pues termina
siendo precisamente es un acto
patriótico para defender y apoyar el
partido y los ideales republicanos y
donald trump y derrochó aunque
verbalmente y aunque públicamente ha
dicho que hay que vacunarse pues su
mensaje sigue siendo bastante
confrontacional frente a la
administración del holding ya los
grandes grandes proyectos y grandes
puntos de política pública de joe biden
y esto ha hecho obviamente pues que la
desconfianza la polarización la división
crezca aún más aunque en las redes
sociales del ex presidente
donald trump estén cerradas aunque
sus mensajes no se filtren tanto entre
los estadounidenses pues él sigue
recorriendo el país y hace unas semanas
empezó a igual michigan en la frontera
entre méxico y eeuu y ha cediendo pues e
impulsando este cuestionamiento a los
demócratas este cuestionamiento a la
administración de joe biden y pues esta
idea de que precisamente no siguiendo
las recomendaciones de la administración
de joe biden pues es más patriótico se
es más republicano y se apoya aún más a
donald trump que recordemos sacó casi
que la mitad de la votación en las
elecciones presidenciales pasadas así
que esa polarización sin duda es uno de
los factores más grandes en el hecho de
que muchos estadounidenses pues no se
hayan vacunado todavía y no se logre ese
70 por ciento de vacunación sin embargo
pues hay esperanza en el hecho de que ya
se ha probado vacunas para menores de
edad la vacuna de fallecer y las
modernas están ya muy encaminadas a que
pronto puedan empezar a aplicarse en
menores de edades ya tienen la
aprobación
la administración de alimentos y drogas
de eeuu así que pues es cuestión de
tiempo de que estos índices en menores
pues bajen aún más y eso apoye aún más
el tema de lograr esta inmunidad de
rebaño que quiere lograr el cobay de no
solamente en adultos no solamente
logrando esa cifra de 70 por ciento en
adultos sino en los colegios y lo
mencionó en su discurso hace unos
minutos en la casa una aunque es
importante que pues en la reactivación
económica los niños vuelvan a los
colegios y precisamente para que los
niños vuelvan a los colegios pues ellos
también tienen que estar vacunados para
que desde ahí no solamente se ataquen
las nuevas variables sino que pues se
ataque la pandemia y este virus pues que
ha cobrado como lo mencionaba el
presidente yo by demás 16 600 mil
muertes en eeuu
cristóbal a usted muchas gracias por
todo este análisis y esta ampliación
recordamos que fue el discurso del
presidente joe biden en el 4 de julio
día de la independencia de eeuu con un
mensaje en el que llama a la unidad a
vacunarse asegura que el hobbit no ha
sido vencido pero
de los ideales patrióticos de eeuu a
ustedes muchas gracias por acompañarnos
en esta emisión quédense con nosotros
que hay más en france 24
[Música]